- I thought the cooties
thing was true, but it's not.
'Cause I kiss my mom all the
time, and I don't get cooties.
- Some boys are meaner to
girls when they like them.
- Some of them are mean.
They pick on you.
- A lot of the boys are very shy.
- A lot of the girls
have crushes on the boys.
- First grade girls are
the nicest girls ever.
- I have one crush.
- I met him in Kinder.
- They have a freckle on their neck.
- He's a little cute.
- She normally wears Frozen shirts.
- He kinda look like, really cool.
It was sun outside so
we put on sunglasses,
and that just made him cooler.
- Yeah, yeah. Everything
she wears, I like.
- He's a good drawer,
he's good at kickball.
- She can hang out with anyone.
Every girl just likes one category.
Dani likes multiple ones.
- I was playing a game with my friends,
and she asked to join.
- We went to summer camp together.
- When I talk to him, I get nervous.
- I feel happy when she's around me.
- We play games,
and we play hide and seek,
and we were born at the same time.
- Sometimes I just know.
- I told one of my friends,
and somebody was listening,
and they told him.
Whenever I try talking to
him, let's just say he runs.
- I have to tell no one.
I would never tell her
that I have a crush on her.
She would be grossed out.
Oh! I got her dollies.
I don't like dollies, but I had to.
- I was just gonna make him a notebook.
- My friend Greg would play wingman,
and he'd find out what
the girl that I liked
was interested in.
I took all the things that she liked,
mashed them up on a piece of paper,
and I wrote a book for her.
- She told me that she was gonna leave
to a different, to Lego Camp tomorrow.
And I was like, very sad.
And we're best friends,
and I have a crush on her.
She doesn't know it.
She doesn't know that, but...
I think she has a crush on me too.